-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Guys, it's a very busy time
in New York City,
because the UN General Assembly
is officially under way.
Yeah. More than
100 foreign leaders are in town
to address the assembly,
while some are just here
to pick up a fiancé for 90 days.
I love when the UN
General Assembly is in session.
There is no greater joy
than watching
the president of Romania
walk into the M&M store.
Seriously, when else
are you going to spot
the president of Latvia holding
one of those restaurant buzzers
outside Bubba Gump Shrimp?
It's like, "Our table is ready.
Let's go."
Of course, the main focus of
this year's General Assembly
is fighting COVID.
Yep, nothing like holding
a superspreader event
to tackle a pandemic.
There's actually some
real concern about
the General Assembly
turning into
a superspreader event,
because -- and this is real --
the UN is using the honor system
to check vaccinations.
-Ooh!
-What? The honor system?
I don't even trust
the honor system
when they give out candy
on Halloween.
It's like, "Please take one.
Oh, I know you're
going to take it.
Honey, they took the bowl.
We don't even
have a bowl anymore."
Next, the UN
is going to be like,
"We believe further conflict
with the Taliban
will be avoided thanks to our
latest pinkie promise."
The first leader
to speak this morning
and address the pandemic
was none other than
the unvaccinated president of
Brazil, Jair Bolsonaro.
Yeah, that's like attending
a weight-loss conference
and hearing, "Please welcome our
first speaker, Colonel Sanders."
After Bolsonaro spoke,
President Biden
then made his address
to the UN General Assembly.
It was the first time he spoke
to a room of full of
world leaders
confidently knowing
that they didn't have him
on mute.
Yeah, Biden talked about
the pandemic, climate change,
and the withdrawal from
Afghanistan.
When he watched, former
president Trump was like,
"Pssh!
I got way more laughs than him.
Way more laughs."
People are talking about this.
Today, the U.S. Space Force
unveiled a uniform prototype
for its members.
Finally. Look at this.
Hmm.
Right now, every New York City
doorman is like,
"Are we in the Space Force?
What?
That's what we're wearing."
Can we see it again?
It looks like a line cook being
yelled at by Gordon Ramsay.
"Go to space with you, donkey!
Go to space!"
Seriously, by the time
you button up that jacket,
the space war is going to be
over, you know?
Yep, that is the new uniform,
until Jeff Bezos
buys the Space Force
and turns it into this.
Yeah, I love that.
He looks...
[ Applause ]
He looks like a mash-up
of Buzz Lightyear and Woody,
doesn't he?
Here's some good news.
Johnson & Johnson announced
its COVID booster shot is
94% effective when given two
months after the first dose.
People who got
the J&J were like,
"Yeah, that would have been nice
to know about three months ago."
Actually, everyone
who got J&J was like,
"We already got boosters.
They're called Moderna. Yeah."
Well, this is great.
I saw that Google Meet --
Google Meet
is going to start automatically
adjusting webcam brightness
in users's browsers.
Yeah. And it's not the only
new feature they're adding.
Take a look at this.
-We here at Google Meet
are excited to announce
a brand-new feature to make your
experience better than ever.
That's right --
when you click "New Meeting,"
it will take you
directly to Zoom.
Google Meet --
at least we're not Skype.
-Yeah, isn't that amazing?
That's amazing.
And, finally, a pair of
107-year-old sisters in Japan
just claimed the title of
world's oldest identical twins.
Yeah, and just to
creep people out,
they stand in the hallway of
their retirement home and say,
"Come play with us."
Guys, as I said before, this
week, the UN General Assembly,
with leaders coming in
from all over the world,
is happening.
They're gonna give speeches.
They're gonna meet each other.
But, sometimes, when
you meet new people,
it can be hard to break the ice,
which is why a lot
of leaders come prepared
with their very own "getting
to know you" icebreakers.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Icebreakers."
-♪ "Tonight Show Icebreakers" ♪
-First up, we have British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson.
His icebreaker is, "Which fork
do you use to comb your hair?"
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It's a nice icebreaker.
-Gets you into the conversation.
Next up, we have
Latvian President Egils Levits.
His icebreaker is...
-Good one.
-This is just icebreaking.
-Yeah, just break the ice.
-Next up is
Finnish President Niinisto.
His icebreaker is, "Sorry,
you might not recognize me
without my Joker makeup."
That's interesting.
It's an icebreaker.
-Yeah.
-Here is Prime Minister
Bennett of Israel.
His icebreaker is, "Do you like
my resting kissy face?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Smooching ]
-Up next, here is
U.S. President Joe Biden.
-Oh.
-His icebreaker is...
-That's his icebreaker?
-Wow.
-Next is Estonian President
Kaljulaid.
Her icebreaker is...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, we have
Prime Minister Modi of India.
His icebreaker is, "Why does
Macy's keep offering me
a part-time job
for the holidays?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a good icebreaker.
-Yeah.
And, finally, here is Brazilian
President Jair Bolsonaro.
His icebreaker is,
"I'm unvaxxed, sashed,
and ready to get trashed."
That's all we have for
"Tonight Show Icebreakers."